9 million square kilometres and getting
larger every year the Sahara is the
greatest deserts on earth even today few
people dare cross its emptiest quarters
but for the Tuareg the legendary people
of the desert this is their kingdom
Arabic and origin the Tuareg have
traveled the Sahara since the 7th
century when the Arabs first invaded
North Africa from the Middle East the
wild terrain is reflected in the nature
of the Tuareg who were among the most
feared people in Africa they looked very
different to the black African tribes on
whom they prayed but over the centuries
the Tuareg interbred with the tribes
surrounding the desert under slaves they
dragged across it and so today's Tuareg
can range in color from light olive to
deep brown in his dark skin al hasan
reflects the mixed jeans of his Saharan
ancestors Thank You Oliver America I'd
say to go somewhere of money that came
amid another circle someone in the
circus remote encounter a distinct
entity
with the salt mines of Bill Maher fading
on the horizon the caravan settles into
a familiar rhythm they will travel
almost 200 kilometers before anything
breaks the skyline over the next 50 days
Al Hasan will cross all of the different
types of terrain that make up the Sahara
but first there is the sand west of Bill
Nye the famous sea of ténéré stretches
for three hundred and fifty kilometers
and Al Hassan's journey begins with the
crossing of this pure ocean of sand
regarded as one of the most beautiful
parts of the Sahara Tenere means nothing
are empty in Tamasheq the language of
the Tuareg
attacker rustle again and Vlasic
together so hard to bear I see Tamara
and it can occur that accent I didn't
cymbal you dig do for it